[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau 7,8
culture au sommaire de ce mercredi 21
septembre michel landi dessinateur et
affichiste a réalisé plus de mille
affiches pour le cinéma international
une exposition retrace sa carrière à
l'espace philippe noiret aux
clayes-sous-bois le dimanche 25
septembre c'est la journée nationale de
lutte contre la mucoviscidose une
maladie génétique est rare à l'étudiant
d'une école de cinéma et leur courtois
va réaliser un court métrage autour de
cette maladie est une société innovante
elle a choisi de mettre en relation
artistes et auto entreprise départ et la
chouette organisée
il était une fois dans l'ouest donne
camillo ou encore paris brûle-t-il ont
un point commun michel landi il est le
créateur des affiches de ses films une
exposition à l'espace philippe noiret
des clayes-sous-bois retrace sa carrière
regardez les images au ciné c'est
patrick jacques de dixmude
donner envie aux gens d'aller voir le
film faire passer une émotion auprès du
public c'est le but du métier d'un fish
est bon bah boire le film et on essaie
de s'en imprégner en effet d en tirer ce
qui
pousse que l'on peut sortir comme visuel
qui puisse attirer le monde il faut
faire moi je dis je fais la fiche
du film que j'aimerais aller voir
alors si c'est un film dans la catégorie
de films que j'aime l'affiché et en fois
mieux bougez mais je me tâte un peu plus
c'est le hasard qui l'a amené à ce
métier en font il était passionné par
les affiches de cirque il a toujours
côtoyé des peintres et était fasciné par
le cinéma michel landi réalisera plus de
mille affiches pour le septième art dont
celle ci datant de 1985 un simple voile
sur le visage de nastassja kinski du
blanc et le titre arem d'arthur geof
loin des contraintes de l'époque où les
noms et visages des acteurs principaux
devait apparaître
voilà un an j'ai pataugé dans ce système
là j'avais même pas vu le film j'avais
le scénario et puis un jour j'avais
tellement marre des jeux des affiches
blanches et trois fois rien comme ça on
verra ce
et saas adaptées rien avec le voile deux
arrêts marraine gérante chances de chez
moi deux minutes j'avais un petit con
qui est j'ai fait ça une audace
récompensée par un césar le premier pour
la profession michel landi croquera
plusieurs affiches de grands films qui
sont à découvrir dans de cette
exposition une autre manière de se
plonger dans l'histoire du cinéma
à elancourt se trouve l'école troisième
l'institut international de l'image et
du son une section est consacrée au
cinéma la filière dont est issu jérôme
roumagne ce jeune réalisateur de 22 ans
vient de terminer cette étude est un
court métrage il parle relations
intergénérationnelles et maladie la
mucoviscidose une maladie rare et
génétique qui touche les voies
respiratoires et le système digestif
regardez
antoine à 18 ans et la mucoviscidose
mais il veut continuer à courir à
l'hôpital il rencontre julie une vieille
dame acariâtre une histoire sorti de
l'imagination de deux étudiants le
réalisateur jérôme roux maille et marie
dels arts la scénariste quand j'étais
plus jeune je suis hélas la star academy
j'ai découvert la maladie comme beaucoup
de personnes en france
en suivant le phénomène grégory
lemarchal et donc c'est de là que qui
est venu voilà cette envie d'en parler
et à ce moment là je savais pas encore
comment pourquoi et puis voilà j'ai
commencé des études de cinéma et le film
de fin d'études était le bon moment pour
en parler
pour crédibiliser le personnage il
fallait rencontrer un pneumologue déjà
pour comprendre la maladie comprend
effectivement que c'est pas quelque
chose qui est forcément physiques c'est
plus dans l'attitude dans peut-être le
comportement aussi qu'on voit qu'une
personne est malade respire pro forme en
juillet 2015 avec l'écriture du scénario
le tournage s'est déroulé fin février
2016 à rambouillet auxerre si un centre
de rééducation
se poser la question voilà deux qui sait
ce personnage donc en l'occurrence on a
un personnage qui est qui atteint de la
mucoviscidose qui aiment le sport ça
c'est le personnage entre guillemets
son aspect caricatural mais parce que
moi j'aime le cinéma que
que je fais que ce à quoi donc c'est à
dire que par exemple sur ma table de
nuit un super picsou géant
al'inverse lui qu'est ce que c'est que
ces passions qui sont pas marqués en
fait dans le sens dans le scénario quoi
victoire meute les vus dans la série
clem prête ses traits à antoine julie la
vieille dame est interprété par une
marque villalonga très en forme ma foi
si pour bioshock je chanterai
à votre âge
franchement justement mon âge pauv' con
faire jouer mart ça a été une pression
supplémentaire déjà parce que voilà non
mais encore à l'école donc on apprend
aussi donc voilà on s'est dit là il faut
pas se planter elle en a vu des grands
et ben voilà la tourne énormément c'est
une personne qui est totalement dévoué
au projet au film est donc finalement
elle se laisse guider et voilà je pense
qu'elle n'a pas été déçu et n'ont en
tout cas pas du tout mais très très
content d'avoir eu sur ce projet c'était
une expérience formidable
respire devrait être présenté dans des
festivals avant d'espérer sensibiliser
le public à la maladie au don d'organes
aux protagonistes resteront les
souvenirs
[Musique]
on reste dans le cinéma galles pineau du
grenier à sel de trappes vous donne
rendez vous pour les lumières du grenier
un programme de grands films classiques
on les écoute bonjour je vais vous
parler des lumières du grenier c'est le
titre que nous avons choisie pour le
programme de grands films classiques que
nous avons concocté pour la saison 2007
2016 2017 vous pourrez aussi évidemment
voir des films de patrimoine dans
chesneau hocine chaînes cinéma voisin la
soirée d'ouverture de la saison au
grenier à sel aura lieu le vendredi 30
septembre à 20h45 avec un ce soir un
ciné concert sur les films burlesques de
charlie bauer charlie bauer c'est un des
génies du début du cinéma au même titre
que chaplin keaton ou même méliès sauf
que lui l'histoire l'a un peu oublié
donc ces films sont toujours fantastique
et nous allons les redécouvrir grâce à
franck ionale franck raynal c'est un
musicien un batteur qui a qui
accompagnera les courts métrages à la
batterie solo et grâce à une bande son
sur ordinateur qu'il a créé sur
ordinateur donc monsieur bricolo c'est
un inventeur loufoque l'accompagnement
musical proposé par franck ionale mettra
en lumière l'audace de ce savant fou en
passant de l'électro à la musique world
et de l'afrobeat au rock le titre du
film je l'ait pas dit mais le titre du
programme c'est les fois l'invention de
monsieur bricolo les tarifs c'est 6
euros le tarif normal mais si vous êtes
si vous avez un abonnement cinéma ce
sera à 3 euros pour vous pensez donc à
réserver au 01 30 69 84 62 et vous
retrouverez évidemment plus
d'informations sur cinéma grenier à sel
points comme
les artistes vivent de leur art et de
leur oeuvre et il faut se font connaître
lors d'expositions qui ne sont pas
toujours faciles à organiser une société
innovante n a choisi d'être une
passerelle entre des artistes et des
entreprises des parrainages secret mardi
20 septembre ils se rassemblaient pour
une première exposition rencontre
regardée
art partagé points comme m'étais dollar
dans vos affaires à rapprocher les
entreprises des artistes c'est le
principe qu'a lancé une société ini
monteyne ce qu'on a voulu faire c'est à
travers cette galerie faire en sorte que
les entreprises puissent louer des
oeuvres d'art qu'on puisse aussi créer
des événements à performance c'est à
dire que on veut rompre on veut casser
on veut impulser une autre image de la
30 artistes et autant d'entreprises se
sont déjà choisis comme christophe
baudin peintre sur plaisir son parrain
les bureaux régionaux d'une entreprise
nationale
c'est une ouverture sur le monde c'est
une ouverture culturelle ça me permet de
rencontrer plein d'autres artistes
d'échanger de créer un réseau et puis
également de rencontrer des partenaires
c'est la possibilité d'exposer dans le
dans la société du partenaire également
et peut-être de louer une toile peut
être de vendre une toile qui sert avec
christophe on a évoqué des parrainages
d'accompagnement
dans différents lieux où il peut montrer
ses toiles on a envisagé au restaurant
d'entreprise par exemple ou parfois des
personnes exposé des produits qu'ils
interviennent et qui montre ses produits
on a évoqué une initiation de mes
collaborateurs à l'art par son
intermédiaire les parrainages
permettront aussi d'organiser des
expositions dans les entreprises mais
aussi des ventes d'oeuvres des artistes
concernés
et comme chaque semaine quelques rendez
vous à noter le premier c'est aux pavés
du canal à montigny le bretonneux
elle propose une rencontre le samedi 24
septembre la librairie accueille
frédérique deghelt l'auteur présentera
libertango son dernier ouvrage le samedi
24 septembre l'espace albert camus de
morale dans sa saison et propose un
spectacle pour tous avec mondiale
cabaret christophe glockner et olivier
denizet présente magique la quête
chanson musique et danse regardez
[Musique]
si vous êtes plutôt opéra et comédie
musicale prenait la direction du théâtre
montansier l'ensemble justin yana sera
sur scène vendredi 30 septembre avec des
enfants à croquer une critique sociale
et de l'humour noir
il y eut deux passants
[Musique]
je t'aime je te
ça ne m'étonne pas de toi
tu m'as dit ça tu m'as dit ça
je te reconnais bien là
[Musique]
le concert de la batterie de le concert
de sages comme des images par donc à lui
à la batterie du côté de guyancourt et
le premier de la saison culturelle on se
quitte avec ce dernier rendez vous il
est comédien et musicien mais ce
spectacle-là se fait tout en sifflant
fred radix sera sur la scène du théâtre
gérard philipe de saint cyr l'école en
regardant l'extrait
[Musique]
attendez attendez à la bande à tomber
alors non pour ce qui est sifflé je fais
le job un nanomètre bon les sopranos
vous rappelle votre note
non vous vous rappelez pas de votre note
alors
[Musique]
je sais pas si vous avez entendu mais à
un moment on était en harmonie
le cetud culture est maintenant terminé
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
mercredi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
les magazines continue sur terré chez 78
[Musique]